alors on va faire un schéma une
interview à l'envers est-ce que c'est
une interview à l'envers oui c'est une
interview vous me donnez les réponses et
bien
[Applaudissements]
voilà maintenant on reste comme ça
ouais c'est très bien compris
les questions alors la réponse mettons
c'est Fabrice Luchini qui est le
meilleur acteur français
Philippe Solers
oh [ __ ] alors
je n'ai jamais lu un livre de comment il
s'appelle déjà
inculte
de merde aussi
Philippe solaire
donc je donne la réponse Laurent Baffie
formidable déjà je parlerai des petits
côtés humains de la personne puis après
tu peux broder là dessus
qui a ce mélange de de grâce d'humour de
talent
de sexe à pile
d'avoir des plus gros seins
qui est à la main droite qui part un peu
en couille
c'est très bien on continue c'est très
bien Guy Bedos
qui ne manque pas de toupet
on allume la lumière
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
tube abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu